well hasn't been a good week for elite
consensus here in Washington Democrats
shut down the government only to
belatedly realize that most Americans
are not on their side they don't think
illegal immigrants are worth closing the
government for meanwhile Robert Muller's
investigation muddles ahead more and
more evidence suggests the FBI is too
ideologically compromised possibly too
incompetent to reach trustworthy
conclusions are we reaching the right
conclusions from these news stories to
check we're inviting as we always do Fox
senior political analyst Brit Hume to
add some clarity of this chaotic picture
Brett thanks for coming on
Thank You Tucker so what I find so
striking we haven't tried people try to
add some clarity I know that you will
that's implied baked in the cake but I
was kind of shocked by this Schumer
story this week because I think she'll
are smart and I think he pays close
attention to poll numbers as politicians
ought to I think and yet they went way
out on a limb shut the government down
over an issue that most Americans don't
consider a top priority how did they do
that
well I think Tucker the my guess is that
Schumer probably did not think this was
a good idea
yeah probably resisted it but there's
the strength of the left branch of his
caucus as such that it reminded me in
the end very much of what happened in
2013 with Ted Cruz and that rump group
of House Republicans who were in
sufficient numbers that they forced John
Boehner who was clearly reluctant he was
then speaker of course to let them go
forward the strategy to shut the
government down to try to lever
President Obama into undoing a big piece
of Obamacare well it failed utterly the
measures of the House pass went nowhere
in the Senate the government shut down
the public did not like it in the
history of the public's liking
government shutdowns is pretty thin and
in the end they all had to back down
well this is the was sort of a mirror
image of that I don't think the leader
liked it but he you know was a good
soldier participated in it
in the end they got there you know they
got their butts handed to them and had
to back down because it did not go over
well and the members in their caucus who
are up for reelection this year could
sense that and a handful of them voted
no on the whole idea on the first
go-round back last week and by the end
of the weekend I think it was clear to
them at least that there's that they
were losing and it was hurting that
could hurt them back home and so they
came out and caved in and soumarin and
the and the filibustering Democrats got
practically nothing it's just remarkable
then Republicans seem a little out of
touch with public sentiment on this to
the new Harvard poll asked people do you
think we need less or more immigration
overwhelmingly less the number of
Americans who want more people to come
from foreign countries and that's the
consensus view in DC on both parties we
need more 12% want more well I wonder
why they're not aware of that none of
them seem aware of that well it depends
on how you which piece of the
immigration issue you're looking at it
the idea that you want more immigrants
than we're now getting I think is you
know that's not that's not popular as
you suggest but when you take it you
break out to say the daka piece of it
right you know and of course these are
people who did you hear that voice
behind me that was a lexer I messaged
Chuck to wake Alexis on his mother
conversation and I asked her all the
time I say Alexa are you spying on me
listen she didn't answer no I could
understand that anyway
any way you look at daca this is a
subset of the immigrants in this country
illegally who came here as we've all
heard said through no fault of their own
when they were young when they were
minors and there's a case to be made
that these people are worthy of some
sympathy had never known any other place
but America is home and to send them
back to someplace they've never been
seems unfair and I think most Americans
that that issue pulls pretty well and it
seems that that's bipartisan bipartisan
support for that and then there's the
question of what you do about the
illegals are already here and their
presence here is not popular as you've
suggested but then the question becomes
is it practical to try to round them all
up
send them home and that's right that's
kind of a bridge too far though
so it you know once you get past the
idea that that you know the general idea
that people don't want more immigration
and they certainly don't want more
illegal immigration it gets complicated
and of course the president I think is
standing on fairly solid ground from his
point of view and wanting a series of
border security measures to go with any
any measure to relieve the daca people
of their of their situation here of
their other yeah potential to be be
deported so that's sort of where we are
in this and you know we got another
negotiation coming up soon and we'll see
how much the Democrats are willing to
give in order to get the the daca repeal
undone I for one am looking forward to
it Brit Hume
thank you for the clarity in that
appreciate it and good luck with Alexa
you bet